it feels like America is now this like
an LLC like a shell Corporation for
these darker Arts that are going on
you know and we used to be able to get
upset at people as a group that that's
one thing that kind of burned me some
like even after 9 11 it was like well
you know the media's like well you can't
be mad at any of these countries you
know it's like
the bat thing
Proactive or whatever
uh uh Corvette
with the uh Coronavirus
you used to be able to give oh [ __ ]
China you could say
somebody made either some rich white
people made it over there trying to [ __ ]
around or somebody made it they're over
there batting around they're over there
you know smoking dope and [ __ ] eating
badass or whatever and now everybody
here's Gotta Wear Master tears used to
be able to get up so you're like [ __ ]
them
but now there's like every you know
there's one Chinese guy on Twitter he's
like we I didn't do it
and so the media they use that they how
it's like you're not allowed to be
every every other place is allowed to
stand up for their beliefs and their
rules
and their countries it seems like and it
feels like we're not allowed to stand up
for ours sometimes
and maybe that's just
maybe the truth is that we are
and we just need to stand up more you
know that's what I wonder for myself
and that doesn't mean I want to live in
some type of unwelcoming place but
um
but definitely the fabric and the
textile of what I've always thought like
the pride I've had in in a lot of
americanism
um and the good parts of it I feel like
uh
man that Fabric's really been stretched
in a lot of ways
um
and it feels like by darker interests
that's what it feels like
and I know the dark arts baby you know
what I'm saying I was born in them
you know I've had spiders in my lungs
dude I know what's going on
and uh
yes so who I mean this could be the
problem and now there's no other land of
just bowed off to
maybe there'll be some type of
Revolution or you know maybe I don't
know or maybe everything's fine and this
is just my perception
maybe uh you know
I don't know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one